welcome to New five-minute game and it's
against hypnotic specter yes I'd I
completely forget forgot who that is he
doesn't have a name in there but he
plays on ice is he for for ages I just
pulled up his car he's got all time high
ratings from ten years ago where I know
I played him with all my accounts
through the years ok so again the
sameish and it's um it's always
interesting to to see the positions in
this very controversial and set up just
um sorry completing a development yet no
uh huh
95 is is actually a bit bit uncommon and
this in this setup of course be 69 85
Bishop a 6 is some maneuver that discern
is common in the news oh but it is
usually played when the center is not
closed with you 65 in this formation
normally you go to e7 and trying to use
the night on the kingside connected with
at 596 and so on the issue is you can
you can play mb6 Bishop a 60 others are
all you want but I play just Queenie to
and then protected and the night is a
bit off site on the queenside so the
question is do I threaten Bishop g5 now
with the pin probably not because on h6
I cannot drop back to h4 a half
interesting so he allows he allows
Knight to f5 I'm not sure that this is
is good but but where's this night going
is it going to be 6 really attending to
to capture him maybe I have got Queenie
to know ok maybe you go here so that all
night p 6 have Queenie to and he doesn't
have night be three I'm not be three
what exchange one of my bishops ok the
bishops aren't probably not so brilliant
at the moment but still I want to
prevent that ok now he is said playing
b6 intending this Bishop a six maybe but
you asked yourself why 97 my back here
back here into f4r harm interesting
so if i go F for now you will take and
we will take and play night to g6 yeah
maybe
this is some an original way into play
not sure that is good but it's
interesting he doesn't want to go g6
this much is clear and if he plays
Knight g6 my idea was to go g3 and f4 in
general g3 f4 was this was my idea and
I'm so on g3 he wants to wants to play
am queen age three this is a this is a
problem Bishop g4 yeah I must prevent
that not much got much of a choice and
this makes g3 f4 difficult but this was
my dear d 3 NF form and one now then the
Queen the queen is not necessarily great
online edge for it also can be M can be
a liability if I play a for now play a
phone now and capture with the bishop
threatening on d6 if he takes rook takes
and I'm very quick on the F file this is
probably good young the night on a five
is just a just a catastrophe yeah I need
to be be quick now we're taking the d6
pawn and if he takes rook takes and
winning another temple so on this is a
very quick way to activate White's
pieces takes takes on f4 rook takes and
roop to f1 and then there's no this is
not survivable I cannot take I think on
f4 yeah exactly and what now he's some
he's intending to play of course Knight
to e5 Bishop to g5 would be would be
good if I can get this in all pawn on e5
pawn to e5 now opening up everything I
this dangerous be five tips hmm takes
and Bishop age six something like this
I'm also thinking just Queen d2 okay
just just 22 threatening Bishop g5 or
Bishop h6 those moves are very dangerous
I think he needs to take on a phone okay
I thought just Knight f6 next move and
it's too much or bishop f6 depending
what is playing Queen c7 Bishop f6 and
entered sits over on g7 takes Queen h6
silver it's just too much on the king
probably needs to go Quinn to f8 this is
the only move most likely and then
Knight f6 s it's dangerous Knight f6
takes yeah this was also also
possibility I wasn't 100% sure what's
best knight takes Bishop takes rook
takes mmm Luke tanks maybe too much okay
i want i want the bishop on f6 the
bishop just look Sam looks enormous
tonight's it's it's even that it is Zac
I'm just I'm just I'm just stupid it's
not enormous or anything it just winds
what where does he go Queen f7 Bishop b5
is over and now just Queen g5 check at
night g65 and black explodes yeah this
is the kind of game you want in the
sameish variation just hacking black to
pieces and wins the Queen
yeah well sometimes not what I'm saying
is actually working at the end Knight a5
is to was just an offside piece you need
to put it on the seven it's just better
to learn to centralize it there are many
many positions where the night is is
fine on a five but here it done it
somehow it didn't really play I mean and
end around here I mean I'm not saying
black ass is lost or something but it's
it's tricky it's at least difficult to
play the computer think so Bishop a
knight to e5 now is fine maybe but it's
so very very dangerous and now this is
very very hard to defend yeah Knight f6
wind snow the computer here gives Queen
f8 with an advantage yeah can Matt it's
possible it's possible in bits you can
only make those quick judgments it was
clear that f6 lost stamp but ok let's
have a look at the Queen move what I
intended was not f6 really and what now
a computer just wants to go Bishop a 6
this is cool I thought and the long run
it's too much on the king maybe this is
so this is wrong also it's possible
2596 of course look at three h4 h5 I
mean for you minute looks terrible but
maybe it's it's still on this is all
based on the fact that these pieces are
off side he can take a pawn but not sure
that this that this helps computers on
minus 14 wide I mean I'm behind piece
down so the computer acknowledges that
there is some serious compensation yeah
that's a that's quite typical for this
for this opening line after here the
computer actually gives why to win with
night with 97 ins instantly maybe have a
look at this quickly here this is
winning we understand them now Queen f8
is not on because of bishop age six and
then you don't have a move if you move
the Queen here then this just leads to
instant mate yeah of course so he needs
to play f6 and give the Queen yeah
interesting game thanks for watching